Stargate Announcement by Christmas
that's the rumor I'm hearing welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
so if you caught my Batgirl movie you'll
know that I had a very long conversation
the last couple of days with a source
that works in Hollywood this Source used
to work for MGM now works for a certain
agency in Hollywood and he gets to hear
lots of rumors from lots of different
places this Source was actually the
first one to ever really talk to me
about Stargates in any detail and he was
the one that first told me about Mark
Fergus and Hawk ostby possibly coming in
and taking over the franchiser at very
least being brought in by Amazon to
reinvigorate the franchise now I am
going to tell you that a lot of what I'm
about to talk about is based on this
person's opinion he talks to lots of
different people and he gets a general
feeling of where these projects are
going they've worked in the industry
their whole life and basically he's as
close as an expert in this field as
we're gonna get
so first of all I'm going to say that
there's been a lot of whispers about
where MGM is at the moment
apparently he still speaks to people at
MGM it's where he used to work after all
and he says the main headquarters in
Hollywood
um it feels completely different now he
says of all the people he speak to says
Amazon obviously come in they've took
over everything each department has now
been absorbed into the equivalent
department at Amazon
there's a lot of Amazon logo start to
appear in the building in different
places and he says it just feels very
much like a different place to work now
this is um
a lot of the creativity feels like it's
been sucked out of the place and it's
just becoming an extension of Amazon
Studios and an office block instead of
the headquarters for one of the world's
oldest Studios but what he has said is
that restructuring process seems to be
coming to an end he said there was a lot
of turmoil four months ago that seems to
be settling down now and they seem to be
getting back to work which is a good
sign for Stargate
he did say to me the fact that Stargate
sg1 SGU and SGA are now back on Amazon
Prime in the United States and he said
soon we'll be around the world is a very
good sign that just shows how much
Amazon really does find the Stargate
franchise to be an important one moving
forwards and one they really want to
exploit in the future
he also said though that a lot of the
rumors have quietened down now he said
he was here in all sorts of different
things a lot of I'm not going to share
with you because well even he said
they're probably not true
um or at very least they were rumors
that were just opinions that were quite
fleeting so I was trying to explain that
by the way if you're new to the channel
don't forget to like subscribe hit the
Bell notifications share the video
wherever the hell you want and you can
even hit the join button because that
really supports the channel if you enjoy
the content also go to side-track.com
for lots of merchandise opportunities
when a new project is building up
towards being green lit there are
approaches the studio will approach
somebody or would you be interested in
maybe working on this project and a lot
of the time they'll say oh you know
maybe yes I'd love to but I've got this
doing happening and I've got this
project coming up and I just don't have
time but those conversations do generate
rumors so this rumors about oh well this
actor might be involved and this sector
might be involved or this producer might
step on board but they never turn into
anything because for whatever reason the
person approached can't do it now that
is quite common is there so a lot of
these rooms go around the person I'm
speaking to though says the interesting
thing is is when the rumors stop
mm-hmm
which is the case here he says a lot of
the rumors have stopped
now he says that is a big indicator that
something is possibly about to get
announced one of the things he did say
in particular was rumors around
showrunners seems to have stopped says
he heard that three or four people have
been approached the rumor mill got going
but about a month ago it stopped that
was when the rumor about Mark and Hawk
basically a surfaced
he says it made no sense to him and I
think I said it in the video before that
when Hall ghost B and Mark Focus were
approached that they were approached
without a showrunner being in place he
believes at least that a showrunner has
got the job
it's not Brad Wright he he thinks he
doesn't think it's Brad right
um and that then they've moved on to
Bringing on Mark and Hawk to sort of
develop where the show wants to go in
the future
so that's the first big bit of news the
next Big Ben news he says
as I say with all the rumors around
actors and stuff going quiet he thinks
that is because the decisions have been
made and
Amazon are notoriously secretive so he
says the shutters have come down
that's interesting this is because
basically that means he thinks a
decision is about to be made and the
decision is about to be then announced
so I pinned him down okay so in your
experience working in this field having
20 30 years of experience in the field
what do you think that means
and his answer was very straightforward
and very short
we'll know by Christmas
[Music]
so obviously I said what does that mean
she says if we haven't had an official
announcement by Christmas about Stargate
then you should be worried because it
won't happen it was basically it was
since if they would they all decide one
way or another
so if they've got a showrunner in place
and they've got a couple of people
thinking about the franchise
that is a big step forwards
but it says but there is now going to be
a time frame you're talking you're
talking about three or four months from
this point when everything starts goes
quiet there's three or four months now
either something will happen or it won't
and if it means if something doesn't
happen it means they're not going to be
going ahead with the project at the
moment
so
I asked so what's what does that mean
for Stargate
we will either have an official
announcement by Christmas
or we will not get an announcement and
there will be nothing this this project
just will not move forward and it'll be
years until we see Stargate potentially
obviously that's an opinion of an
Insider somebody that works in the field
somebody that talks to people that talks
to people and gets the rumors that are
wandering around Hollywood but what do I
think
this Source has told me lots of things
over the last 12 months and stuff that
has become really interesting he was the
guy that first told me that Brad Wright
was almost certainly not going to get
his script made
um
you know he's told me lots of things
he's told me a few things that I've then
not come to pass
um he says he recently told me that
there was
um a lot of effort being put forward
towards a 2001 Space Odyssey
um TV series to go on to Amazon
apparently Amazon are currently shelving
that idea
um but he said basically Amazon Disney
HTTP max they're all shelving lots of
ideas at the moment the cost and living
crisis mean that the increase in
streaming services just isn't happening
like it was the money is drying up so a
lot of streaming services right now are
really having second thoughts about lots
of projects that they were about to
green light
so this guy knows what he's talking
about and I and I trust him as he's
talking about
it's interesting to me that he's talking
about this thing about how when The
Whispers stop that's when something
happens because that that kind of makes
sense to me and that the Amazon are
approaching different people
um you know they talk to other people
Whispers go around any industry I've
worked in office box before that seems
to be how it works to me
um so
but when a decision gets made that's
when people start locking down and
that's when people stop Whispering it
seems so yeah maybe we are about to get
a decision so what would I say
a decision by Christmas
it's only about three months
so
that would be nine months eight nine
months into
um Amazon's ownership of MGM that seems
to me a reasonable time frame
considering
the mess that MGM were in and the
restructuring that was required
um say six months to restructure the
business seems to be they've done that
now and they're getting back to work we
are starting to hear a few rooms of a
few other MGM products
um maybe being green lit which is a good
sign so yeah it seems to me that the the
time frame considering everything we now
know about MGM that obviously Amazon
didn't when they bought it
makes sense
so hey maybe we're about to get the best
Christmas present ever
[Music]
because maybe we're about to get an
announcement of our favorite TV show
coming back
that Stargate might be about to reopen
it but guys get in the comments and tell
me what you think about this rumor and
I'm going to underline again rumor based
on an opinion of somebody I speak to
that works within the industry
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you think as you always do if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and consider
becoming a fully financial side tracker
hit the join button because that really
supports the channel
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]